hey how are you oh I'm horrible mr. riah  yes seems to be a recurring issue anga  am i a passionate bird oh yes but why  does it matter that we're not the same  look Bobby the anger might be contagious  he started it I am a pig what's a pig  show them how we do it  how you doing is that what I think it is  scuse me does a fragile right not your  you all make it I will get feel  unwelcome and you're not asking basic  questions well this just got awkward  doesn't anyone see what's going on here  the whole world is in danger and it's up  to us to stop them anyone knows what  these pigs are up to it's mighty eagle  wisdom get out of there don't spit in  his mouth don't swallow it mmm  it's him  Oh  Oh  horrible turn of events horrible  and on managing our anger through  movement eagle heron pika warrior  mountain tree rabbit focus keep pigeon  and of course downward duck look